face guns and a lovable Japanese mascot
the Final Act of bullet train is
jam-packed with tie-ins callbacks and
double crosses here's how it all plays
out spoilers ahead
the third active bullet train begins
with Camus father the Elder boarding the
train at the stop right before Kyoto
except for a few key characters there's
no one left on the train some think the
white death insured by buying out all
the other seats somehow the Elder is
aware of what's been happening there so
when Prince the first person he meets on
the now largely empty train informs him
his son has perished he tells her she's
mistaken as Prince storms off the Elder
joins ladybug to discover that Kimura is
indeed alive surprisingly lemon who was
also believed to have been murdered by
Prince is still ticking too nonetheless
the train contains an excessive number
of bodies including the Hornets the wolf
and tangerine not to mention the why
deaths mysteriously murdered son as they
approached Kyoto station the quartet of
men forms in an easy Alliance in the
hopes that they don't become the white
desk next victims of course against the
white death's massive goons there's not
all that much of a stance they can make
but they're determined to try lemon
moves to the front of the train to see
if he can take control of it the Elder
ways to confront the white death after
years of planning his revenge against a
Crime Boss for murdering his wife
and despite his terrible luck ladybug
decides to put himself first in a line
of fire as they reach the end of the
line
as the train comes to a stop ladybug
exits allowing both he and their viewers
to see the white death for the first
time on the station platform up until
this point the white death is treated
much like Bill from Quentin Tarantino's
two-part film Kill Bill he is often
mentioned and his presence hangs like a
shroud over the proceedings and just
like Bill the white death's face has
only shown later on unfortunately for
ladybug the white death thinks he is
actually a man named Carver ladybug's
hated co-worker who bowed out of the job
that ladybug is currently trying to
survive Carver was responsible for
staging the accident that killed the
white death's wife now the white death
has gone out of his way to ensure that
every assassin who had something to do
with the incident is on the train so he
can take them all out at once he's happy
to start with ladybug despite ladybug's
protest that he isn't the man the white
death thinks
before the white death dispatches
ladybug the two henchmen who have been
ordered to open the briefcase ladybug
was supposed to steal finally complete
their task however earlier in the film
Prince got camura to crack the case's
code and rigged it to blow when it was
opened again so as soon as the white
desk goons lift the case as lit it
explodes blowing ladybug back onto the
unmoving train followed by the white
death and several henchmen this buys
ladybug enough time to escape the white
desk clutches the white death is also
distracted by another issue Prince whose
every move has been about assassinating
the crime Lord when the white death
enters the train is confronted by Prince
and she makes it clear that the reason
she's so determined to take him out is
that he's her father princess grievan
seems to be that the white death never
paid attention to her because she's a
girl while most people would seek
therapy to cope with the rejection
Prince has gone another way and even as
she waves a gun in her father's face she
still pursues her end game her father is
known for killing anyone who crosses him
and Prince expects that's exactly what
he'll do to her however earlier in the
movie in anticipation of this exact
moment Prince rigs are going to backfire
killing whoever pulls the trigger the
spider tears princess actually
anticipating besting her father
unfortunately while the white death
accepts the gun he declines to kill
Prince leaving her feeling slighted once
again
the white death next encounters the
Elder who the white death recognizes as
one of his predecessors henchmen years
ago the Elder was suspicious of the
white death and warned his boss of his
duplicitous nature unfortunately his
boss didn't listen resulting in the
white death taking over his entire
operation and setting fire to the eldest
house killing the eldest wife the irony
is that even though the two men hold
deep grudges against one another both
are motivated by the demise of their
spouses in other circumstances they
might have been part of a great support
system for one another but neither
character has any plans to hug it out
now the pair begins a brutal brawl just
as lemon figures out how to get the
train moving again however since lemon
has made it clear that the kids series
Thomas and Friends which revolves around
the anthropomorphize train Thomas the
Tank Engine is his personal Guide to
Life the opportunity to drive a train
has to be a thrill for him
whatever thrill lemon feels quickly
wears off when he realizes he doesn't
know how to control the train it's
traveling a Breakneck speed and he can't
slow it down if that weren't bad enough
as ladybug joins him he points out that
they're on a collision course with
another train coming in the opposite
direction on the same track when a group
of the white desk goons appears lemon
volunteers to take them on leaving
ladybug to the bigger challenge of
stopping the train each of them tries
their best but the train still Collide
in a spectacular crash yet Against All
Odds the train ladybug lemon and the
others are on endures a substantial
amount of damage but manages to stay on
the tracks despite that small victory
the train is still hurtling down the
tracks with no sign of stopping so
ladybug continues to work on figuring
out the emergency brake as lemon fights
the white death's goons apparently
working with ladybug instead of against
him as he has most of the train ride
makes lemon feel a bit warm and fuzzy
thanks
man oh that show's real broke well
ladybug has touched the moment doesn't
last because that's the train speeds
over a bridge lemon jumps out of the
train with one of the white desk men
into the water below
Elsewhere on the train the battle
between the Elder and the white death
continues the men initially seem well
matched unfortunately the white death
quickly manages to turn things around
after all you don't earn the nickname
the white death if you aren't accustomed
to Doling out a substantial amount of
well death for a moment it looks like
the white death is going to add the
Elder to his undoubtedly lengthy list of
victims but then Kimura who between
being shot in the guts and massively
hungover hasn't been especially useful
until this point picks up a water bottle
rolling along the floor and tussles out
the white death's head stopping him
before he can deal his final death blow
as a flashback reveals a water bottle
has played a key role throughout the
story not only did lemon get the bottle
of water for free while buying another
beverage but it was also the water that
ladybug filled with sleeping powder that
lemon drank just in time for it to kick
in as Prince shot him causing her to
believe she'd killed him once again the
water bottle shows up just in the nick
of time ensuring camera can save his
father's life
in the front of the train lady Burgers
finally found the handbook with
instructions in English which includes
information about how to deploy the
emergency brake
[Music]
so ladybug instead just pulls out the
entire emergency brake mechanism wires
and all it gets the job done but it
isn't pretty the screeching breaks bring
the train to a stop way too fast causing
it to jump the tracks as the train
careen's out of control the momentum
causes ladybug to fall back through the
cars and while he's sits in the head
with a coffee pot along the way the
bulbous costume of momomon an anime
character with its own themed car on the
train breaks his four the vehicle
finally comes to an inelegance stop in
the middle of what appears to be an
otherwise tranquil Village
ladybug Kamura and the Elder exit the
train they're all worse for wear but
miraculously still alive they're
followed by a furious white death he
once again goes after ladybug whom he
believes as Carver however his Gunners
run out of bullets so he grabs the gun
he took from Prince still unaware it has
been rigged to backfire so as soon as
the white death pulls the trigger the
gun explodes in his face and he sinks to
the ground dead and with half his head
missing immediately afterward an
extremely disheveled Prince appears in
the doorway of one of the remaining
train cars it's unclear where she's been
all this time it's my love
that delivered my father's cups and my
feet with narcissism on this chick
fortunately neither they nor the viewers
have to find out because a truck runs
Prince over seemingly bringing her life
to an end or at least setting her up for
a lengthy Hospital stay
as ladybug Kimora and the Elder walk
away from the destruction of the train
following princes to mice ladybug's
Handler pulls up in a car while she
tries to deny it ladybug knows Maria's
intention was to rescue him he's so
touched that he gets teary-eyed as they
walk back towards Maria's car to leave
ladybug informs her that he no longer
believes in luck especially his bad luck
now he just believes in fate ladybug's
change of heart makes sense and viewers
may even feel it's a long time coming
especially since throughout the movie
many of the things he's deemed bad luck
could actually be seen as good if looked
out from another perspective for example
consider when he wasn't able to exit the
train earlier in the film was planned
because the wolf was coming in the same
door he was trying to go out while the
Wolves violent attack on him was
unexpected ladybug ultimately wasn't her
badly and even managed to inadvertently
take out the wolf before things could
spiral to out of control ultimately it
was a pretty positive result for ladybug
even if the situation wasn't exactly
ideal as ladybug explains his new
fate-based philosophy a poll Falls over
crushing Maria's car while ladybug might
have previously chalked up the incident
to his bad luck now he wonders if it
could actually be a good thing
viewers may not spend too much time
thinking about he was driving the truck
that hit Prince however the movie uses a
mid-credit scene to fill in the blank
before the film wraps up the movie
flashes back to the moment after lemon
jumps from the train and lands on the
water below he takes out the white Dash
henchmen that fell with him goes out of
the water and finds a road where he sees
a small truck with a photo of lemons and
tangerines on the side lemon doesn't
miss the not so subtle symbolism and
takes the truck as his own now that his
brother and longtime partner Tangerine
is dead it's not clear what could be
next for lemon but at least his getaway
seems to be going well and perhaps was
supposed to be a final commentary on
fate he drives into the village where
the train has crashed and as he heads
down the road he sees prince in front of
him instead of hitting the brakes he
presses the accelerator speeding into
the young woman who tried to kill him
with her final violence act another in a
long string of violent zags throughout
the movie Bullet train comes to an end
[Music]